Ultra pass born in part of a tweet I put
out there um right as Co was hitting
where I said hey wouldn't it be great if
the government knew who we were and uh
we each had a unique identifier and then
uh if for example that there was a
pandemic um and they wanted to send us
money they could do so really really
easily and straightforwardly uh and so I
put that out in the world and then you
ran with it to the point where now it's
real
uh which I'm super excited about um so
talk about how you came to ultra pass
and what Ultra pass is so what we
learned is or what the problem we needed
to
solve was how do we share this high
value private
information locked away in these Stylo
databases in a way that simplifies
people's lives empowers them
gives them agency over their own
information and absolves the custodians
of that data from privacy breaking
privacy laws like how do we do that if
we can solve that problem then maybe we
can unlock the data in ways that
simplify people's
lives and that's what we began to build
um that's what Ultra pass does what we
are is a digital trust platform
that
facilitates the sharing of verified data
now it's words what does that actually
mean is say I I'll I'll use an example
and what we do is not limited to
governments and programs because what we
do is it's going to affect everybody
everywhere um but verify data
exchange which is what we provide is
going to become ubiquitous
around the planet and to give you a
sense of scale Shopify simplifies
e-commerce right and e-commerce is
freaking big right Ultra pass simplifies
verified data exchange it's it's it's it
affects everything so what do I mean
I'll give you an example in
healthcare um and what I want what I
hope is some of my examples resonate
with your listeners and they go Ah
that's such a problem we can fix that
the answer is yes so let me give you
some examples so if you've ever needed a
second opinion from a doctor you have to
get your medical records from the first
person to the second person yep and
health records are really sensitive
private information so the doctor one
can't just send it to doctor two right
what you have to do is go to doctor two
fill out a form and the doctor that says
I want you to get my records the doctor
then faxes it yep facts to the first
doctor it may go through it may not go
through if it goes through somebody's
got to pick it up and then they got to
send your
records however they send
them
mail electronically who knows to the
second doctor and you hope it gets there
before your
appointment that's friction that's
painful so what is ultra pass do well we
don't actually do this today but we I'm
interested in doing this you have you
have the capacity to do it yes exactly
we want to work with the electronic
medical records companies what we could
easily do is um Dr a issues your medical
records back to you similar to how an
airline issues you a boarding pass and
then you when you set up when you when
you create your appointment with the
second doctor and says hey do you have
your medical records yes will you share
it with us yes they will requests from
your phone your medical records and now
you share the records with the doctor it
happens all at the time of appointment
done now what's just happened the doctor
gave you your records you then gave it
to the second
doctor that's verified data exchange now
there's a lot of technology that goes
into it couple of important points
one the individual the patient can't
tamper with the information that they're
moving there it's their record but they
can't change
them it's it's tamper proof two the
recipient the verifier the second doctor
can trust the information you've sent
because cryptographically they can
confirm that that your medical records
were given to
you by a certified doctor so now they
can trust who issued it and they can
they can know you didn't tamper with it
now they can trust the information
they've received without having to go
back to the original doctor and say hey
did you send it
that issuer holder
verifier
relationship is what we promote that's
what we call this verified data exchange
model issuer holder verifier we make
that happen in every
industry every in any place any use case
where holder needs to move in their
information from point A to point B in a
verified tamperproof way that's what we
do okay so so you have this verifi data
exchange uh platform um so number one
can you describe a few other use cases
aside from my health data which makes
perfect sense to me um and it could be
actually life-saving or super handy um
but what what are some other use cases
that we could get excited about
potentially I'll give you two one would
be in the area of uh Civic engagement so
if you've gone through the process of
applying for SNAP and getting food
stamps you go through you provide a lot
of
information um to the to the program uh
in person interviews it's you know it's
it's
challenging at the end of that process
what we can do is hook in with that
agency and allow them to issue back all
the information they collected from that
applicant and provide it back to them to
their phone and now when that individual
goes and applies for public housing
rather than go through the entire
process from the start providing all the
same information they just share their
information the application gets
instantly approved not just filled out
but approved because all the information
has all already been vetted by snap and
public housing can determine the
validity of the information being shared
so it instantly approved so now imagine
that in you know multiply that by 10 by
50 by every program you basically have
to go
through something once and repeat it
over and over again simply and easily
the the ability or the impact on burden
the impact on efficiency
the impact on customer experience
enormous and the use cases are are
really unlimited so that's a case in
like the in in in Social
Services uh another one would be when
you uh register to
vote at the conclusion of that process
where you've registered you get issued a
uh digital credential with your your
voter registration now imagine when it's
comes time to vote in a primary or a
referendum or an election you open up
your mobile voting app um which is going
to verify that you are you by way of
your uh Board of Elections credential
and now you can vote from your phone in
a way that is identifi that that secures
your identity um yeah that so these are
Big Ideas and this is not Science
Fiction it's it's happening right
now hey YouTube glad you're in enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you